how's it going my name is pirata welcome
back to condom mmm we fell down this
hall and other than that I don't really
know what to do
this sides bucket don't scare me
whoa bucket you're badass Wow
how are you glass inside bucket you're
weird bucket how did this end up
oh nevermind I am this smart man that's
what they call me mr. smarty I probably
can move this come on man I can't huh
chase it
oh there's a matter right there come
climb ladder if you don't like a Danny
sure to climb a ladder if you like a
dance shoot oh we're up here again
cool hairs Oh doors like now don't hit
me I don't care how are you here before
I'll be backstage now cool
I feel famous that's how you walk stairs
like a badass
alright
James creepy out I don't know about this
brother
oh no school you're going to the school
I have that ball butit Baudette Oh
school yeah [ __ ] yeah boot it
yeah pretty lead to this see if we can
kick it over the fence I told ya I'm
stupid bald all right
wait ah speaking Thomas
I'm so we died from an India guy was
pretty [ __ ] late at being in yeah no
now we got what hey hey
I just died man show some respect bro
another one
you can't kill me oh god damn it if you
don't like it any [ __ ] deodorant
bring it oh gee you got Jesus on your
side boot but Oh black honey [ __ ] do
they do that goddamn [ __ ] they got
Johnson [ __ ] now shove this balls uh
[Music]
there's one more I knew it
come on Brad oh [ __ ] me [ __ ]
submachine here to like it then sure to
put a boot if you don't like it then you
[ __ ] spray their [ __ ] they really
aren't generous with ammo uh I guess
here no well then here then no it's just
a place for them to spawn I guess
god dammit I think we're going in this
hole here alright there's a door budget
are you God
rendered Baga it disappeared
oh well ception
trip wall m14 [ __ ]
duck under I don't see why not
what the hell are you guys doing making
love right in front of like your face
he's like oh yeah okay
no but seriously that we need progress
here there are some health kits cool I
think you were supposed to use this
while fighting them probably it's the
case why do you think about that
now we've can probably going in no all
right cool
I don't mind I don't mind oh you have to
go there I can't go of course it's so
stupid
Oh badass mode activate come here oh no
I never mind
I'm doing
someone heard in the locker
I like lockers I totally understand this
oh we're splitting a mess again she's
still alive I thought we killed her or
something all right probably up here no
where where where why what what is it
what transfer one data what I never
didn't I don't even know it here's
someone down there whatever all right
fine
well
huh whoa it's right there boom there we
go all right call
best way to open a door ever here's
someone in there grabbed rat fire [ __ ]
are you doing her money
you're not a dancer birds aren't
supposed to dance keep telling her it's
[ __ ] creepy whoa wait they really
like to run they're never there ever
it's like it one time I wish it were
just worried [ __ ] there yeah
this is alright climb through call I
mean I slide through this whoa are just
badass my way through whoa
wow that's gotta hurt take this [ __ ]
what are they doing I'll let them fight
each other
hey I like it alright and then whoa nice
that's pretty good it's pretty good I
meant to do that of course [ __ ]
lockers
all right so where are we going done
this start with a good and good that was
a really good Spanish man really good
take it to the face wasn't really too
different
alright here we go shut right ah kurta
got him
okay I got him I can't turn on the
showers
looks like someone vomited in the shower
or something it's okay
what a shovel here all right goddamn it
I can't pass how many - all right I
don't need more
I don't need less either I will kill
them all [ __ ] ass now go here where do
I find a shovel
don't disturb le shovel
let's get to FA chai Bailey this is good
right
it says ila Bieber goddamn bangers in
their lockers in school the trail just
ends at a bank of lockers inside every
JJ
ah that is grass like blood everywhere
never mind I'll take a little photo
[Music]
where the [ __ ] of his penis [ __ ] of
what what the hell beep already sorry
bro but you're [ __ ] ugly oh wait
there's an error
no it's disappear oh here we go
there we go there we go all right sub k
beds of what oh my gosh this is like her
I got damnit huh that means I got a
replay everything and that face too oh
well I hope I got it on the recording
just keeps [ __ ] anyway like a very
annoyed sorry by the short episode so
forgot to come Road today and I'll see
you next episode of we're at makes it
stay awesome bro
[Music]
half of the stuff that's going on was I
supposed to find something for this I
didn't really get anything
[Music]
now